bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 18
avril le château de breteuil continue sa
modernisation de compte cette année
c'est la princesse foden qui fait peau
neuve et nous découvrirons la nouvelle
mise en scène en 2014 il tente un
tremplin musical alors que le groupe n'a
que deux semaines les red bull king ball
aime se lancer des défis et le jeune
groupe sont avec nous en plateau 150
photographies qui interroge
l'association versailles image a demandé
à ses adhérents de réfléchir à la notion
de territoire la réponse est dans leurs
clichés exposés au domaine de madame
elisabeth depuis 40 ans le château de
breteuil fait vivre l'un de ces
héritages la féerie des contes de
charles perrault qui était un état
proche de louis de breteuil qui était
lui ministre des finances de louis xiv
huit contes sont remis régulièrement à
jour et pour 2018 c'est peau d'âne qui
s'est refait une beauté regarder il
était une fois un peu à l'écart du
château là où l'on entend les oiseaux
chanter le lavoir un lieu de la vie
d'autrefois celle du 19e siècle qui
accueille depuis une trentaine d'années
une princesse
henri françois et séverine de breteuil
au début des années 80 commencé à
installer des contes de perrault dans
les dépendances le premier était le
petit chaperon rouge dans la maison de
poupée sur le terrain de jeux en 2018
dans le lavoir nous avons modernisé
remis au goût du jour avec des sons et
lumières technologies plus modernes
cette les enfants maintenant
recherche
la technologie il faut que ça bouge plus
interactif donc le comte tatic comme il
y à 30 ou 35 ans n'était plus vraiment
au goût du jour
budan c'est moi
d'une cage dans cette affaire un compte
à l'animation originale aux dalles et
son histoire prennent vie grâce à un
vidéoprojecteur sa robe devient un écran
3 mois de travail ont été nécessaires
pour garder l'histoire du lieu cette
fois ci le personnage parle de lui à la
première personne et peau d'âne apparaît
au public de manière assez étonnante et
va dévoiler son histoire peau d'âne
immortalisé en 1970 par jacques demy
redevient ici celle de charles perrault
c'est un des premiers comptes qui a été
écrit par charles perrault envers la
version en prose a été réécrite au
xviiie siècle n'est pas de charles
perrault et lacets sont les mots de
charles perrault qu'on entend les mots
du xviie siècle
j'ai décidé de ne présenter qu'un
extrait du compte comme on relit le
compte à un lieu de la vie d'autrefois
j'ai évoqué le passage ou peau d'âne se
retrouvent et se réfugie dans une ferme
où elle va nettoyer loges des cochons et
lavez les torchons une partie de
l'histoire à découvrir lors d'une visite
du château et à compléter chez soi en
ouvrant à nouveau son livre de contes de
fées et voir si la princesse l'écu
heureuse avec nous en plateau quatre des
cinq membres du groupe et bolling ball
le groupe aux saint quentinois alors
raphaël sammartino jean baptiste break
j'en attends duo et pierre-yves joncour
alors c'est un groupe à une trajectoire
assez rapide vous avez débuté en 2014
comment on dit que vous rencontrez déjà
ou là alors le début si je pensais givet
qui a expliqué un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé entre l'état avec pilot on était
dans la même année l'école d'ingénieurs
et puis
on parlait un peu mais pas forcément de
façon régulière et à la fin de la
troisième année on savait qu'on jouait
tous les deux d'un instrument et
derniers jours on est tous les deux
allées à la soutenance
et puis il était là on a discuté et il
m'a dit bah si tu veux tu peux venir
jouer on a repris la salle avec l'aumône
l'un des guitaristes du prom de mon
premier groupe
si tu veux on peut tu peux venir nous
rejoindre et voir ce que ça donne et du
coup j'y suis allé en septembre et dès
septembre et un enseignant est lancé
dans l'ain dans l'aventuré parce que ça
direct fonctionner en fait du kundé la
première répète c'était déjà ça c'est
que ça marche
c'est un marché bien s'amuser bien vous
êtes cinq garçons cinq styles
complètement différents ce qui fait que
vous avez fait votre propre sauce disons
qu'on est assez éclectique on écoute
tous des choses différentes même si ça
tourne mais un général un peu autour du
rock mais ça va du plus ou moins lourds
musicalement et puis après ça s'est fait
petit quoi il ya un peu de tout et on a
trouvé notre truc est donc c'est ça qui
nous est ce qu il arrete résister dans
une catégorie comme souvent on le fait
dans l'industrie médicale ont finalement
vous pourriez intéressé différents sites
différents groupes de personnes
différents spectateurs or nous on est
plutôt dans les styles à la fois stoner
bluesy hard rock métal
et devenir un peu tout jean baptiste et
du jazz en avenir avant qu'on commence
cette formation des jeunes mais très
métal raphaël beaucoup plus j'imagine
que c'est un partage d'expériences à
chaque fois quand vous créez vous créez
tous les simples où il y en a un qui
écrire qui composaient chacun mène sa
petite patte mais ça dépend des fois il
ya des morceaux qui ramène former tout
près tout fait y est juste et à écrire
les paroles défendre ou l'infirmer
n'arrive comme ça puis on travaille
ensemble
les laborantins construc alors j'ai 17
ans et 800 2014 vous vous lancer dans
une aventure déjà la création du groupe
et josh harris quasiment à la même
période comment vous dit allez on se
donne un mois deux semaines concret
comme ça alors qu'on sait que souvent
ego de musique beaucoup d'heures de
répétitions
sachant vous êtes des amateurs vous avez
une vie à côté mais en fait ça a
tellement bien marché au début que
y'avait pas forcément énormément besoin
de travail de base ce qu'ils avaient
déjà kg avait déjà des compositions à
eux et quand je suis arrivé ils m'ont
directement mis dessus et c'est vrai
qu'on a travaillé assez rapidement et
est très très rapidement ça c'est fait
et du coup bain mathieu mathieu rémy qui
s'occupait de lui et c'est malin on l'a
où on répétait aller à l'époque nous a
dit pas vous avez qu à participer au
tremplin et on a dit vas-y c'est bon on
y va avec une belle histoire à la sortie
non pas la première fois
la deuxième fois c'est marrant parce que
mon petit secret il était que tous les
trois la base est justement avant ce
tremplin
gillet qui m'a proposé de venir écouter
un peu ce qu'il est ce qu on avait déjà
joué ensemble
puisqu'on travaille dans la même société
où il ya une salle de musique et du coup
il nous a dit madiba bien et ça y est
tout du coup je suis venu j'ai essayé
après mon faible écoute on fait un
tremplin dans che plutôt bien neuf jours
faut écrire trois ou quatre chansons
premier tremplin on fait rentrer un
quatrième larron voit le jour avant mais
du coup ça s'est bien passé on a passé
un très bon c'était notre premier
concert ensemble direct du coup ça a été
très chaud mouvements et tendances
quand je vais en janvier 2017 vous
sortez votre premier album et je vous
propose qu'on écoute on extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
pour la démo
son
[Musique]
on vient d'écouter phoenix c'est le
premier album janvier 2017 on est à
peine plus d'un an vous êtes déjà sur le
second vous profitez de ce que vous avez
créé peut-être pour faire des concerts
bon alors en train de finir le deuxième
album ouais donc là on fait une petite
pause en ce moment concerne pour se
consacrer pleinement à l'album mais du
coup entre temps on a un art autres
commencé à tourner est vraiment juste
pour l'album ans consacrés à qu à ça ça
va bientôt final un jour un album en
janvier 2007 un album en 2018 ça c'est
que vous n'arrêtez jamais d'écrire en
fait c'est on s'auto produire sans qu'on
fait tout de a à z on s'enregistre on
fait tout nous-mêmes on a un ami qui
ingé-son et avec qui on partage aussi le
projet quoi mais du coup c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de temps donc de tout faire en
même temps pas évidents à défendre les
petites galères son sac l'album réduit
son oreille mais qui sortent plutôt
maintenant on fait au mieux pendant
l'essai d'avancé au maximum 7 8 à fond
on avance là on est presque au bout
faisant des tours justement il ya un
clip qui va sortir
ouais alors il ya un pic est prévu alors
on n'a pas la date encore on veut pas
dire de bêtises donc on va pas dans
cette date mais qui devrait sortir
incessamment sous peu
l'album aussi qu'ils devraient suivre
bah les deux devraient arriver quasiment
en même temps peut-être vise avant l'été
ouais ça serait bien et vous restez dans
la continuité du premier vous aller plus
loin par des rencontres vous avez pu
faire lors de concerts par exemple
bassoues promis on n'avait pas de le
prendre notre premier bassiste
venez nous nous quitter et du coup c'est
raf et pilou qui se sont occupés des
basses sur cet album et
et là on a un bassiste la cinquième
personne qui n'est pas là et en fait ça
change tout ça vraiment sa chance sur
une même niveau composition et rapporte
sa petite pierre à l'édifice c'est
vraiment et totalement différent l'album
est totalement différente dit j'ai déjà
juste par sept par ce fait là en fait et
puis elle a déjà apporté sa patte comme
l'avait fait chacun sait ça et c'est
vraiment très intense est vraiment très
intéressant et surtout que surtout que
les on a bien évolué quand même pas au
niveau du style ça que le premier était
plus folk le beau coup de pub ou de deux
parties folk et bien c'est un peu moins
folk un peu plus il existe en dire un
peu plus voyez un peu plus lourd un peu
avec beaucoup plus de 10 ce taux est de
choses comme ça je vous parlais d'un
clip on va regarder un teaser
[Musique]
au ghana
mais non
mais non mais non
[Musique]
pourquoi ce titre là ses premiers frais
celui qui vous semble le plus abouti
seul morceau qui nous entraîne le plus
je pense aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le
truc où on se lâche à fond quoi même en
concert etc les retours qu'on en a aussi
de grandes parties de notre public c'est
que c'est avec ce morceau japon à
l'armée une bonne claque donc on a eu
envie un petit peu de mettre ça sur un
clip quoi et alors pourquoi qui 6 bd va
alors la grosse question c'est pourquoi
on écrit des chansons en fait on a
vraiment un ressenti par rapport à
chaque morceau ce que le morceau nous
inspire bas on essaie de le mettre
c'est une histoire à côté vous remettre
ça sous forme on va dire et du coup
c'est vrai que c'est ce que on est on a
co écrit ce texte avec avec jean
baptiste et on va c'était assez rigolote
se met un peu là dedans et j'ai trouvé
un petit peu cet univers un peu
rock'n'roll un peu à la cdc avec highway
to hell fin des exemples comme ça donc
du coup ça nous a un peu inspiré
répondre oui et comme comme pour le pour
le point pour le tout les tout ce qu'on
a fait depuis le début c'est de l'auto
production 100% de dire que c'est nous
qui avons fait les prises de prise
d'imagés notamment fait que quelques
images de créations si vous êtes
vraiment touche-à-tout et votre
actualité on espère on va la suivre sur
tv 78 et on peut aussi vous suivre sur
votre page facebook
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu en
plateau et puis on espère vous revoir
bientôt et surtout annoncer la sortie de
votre album et je vous propose
maintenant de passer à une page cinéma
[Musique]
et pour le coup de coeur cinéma de la
semaine on part à elancourt célébre aux
conditions de cette qui vous donnent
rendez-vous alors le coup de coeur de
signer cette semaine c'est évidemment si
je puis dire place publique
le retour du fameux duo à la fois deux
comédiens formidables est aussi le
scénariste bacri jaoui donc il a fallu
attendre 5 ans pour les retrouver et les
voilà de retour avec comme d'habitude
une comédie on va dire cinglante
désenchanté sur les arbres de notre
monde notre société actuelle alors ça se
passe dans une famille recomposée enfin
des composés qui se retrouvent à
l'occasion d'une fête organisée dans un
jardin comme souvent chez les batteries
à la nature et les jardins on se promène
et on va retrouver tout ce petit groupe
avec un animateur de télé un peu has
been son retour qui évidemment joué avec
beaucoup de suavité par jean pierre
bacri et son ex qui elle s'appelle
hélène dans le film et continuer à
croire en ses idéaux et se bat pour les
défendre et les imposer
avant ça t'as vu ce qu'on prend dans le
bouquin de nina à cause d'une position à
cause du beau sich which shows
jalousie c'est vraiment tout le temps ça
ne puise quand on vivait ensemble une
pro b avec la terre entière sait jamais
vous n 4 en séance un petit sourire qui
que je suis en train de faire donc voilà
c'est cinglant c'est suave ces
attachants c'est bourré d'humour bourré
d'humour noir
ça ressemble à la vie c'est très humain
et c'est pour ça qu'on aime bacri jaoui
donc à voir cette semaine au cinéma
ociné cette place publique qu'il soit
réalisateurs comédiens chanteurs ou
encore écrivain artiste retourne de
temps d'une après-midi dans leur
établissement pour échanger avec des
élèves le 9 avril dernier le collège
raymond poincaré de versailles retrouver
son élève franck télé aujourd'hui
réalisateur il a notamment signé la
sphère sk ou les hommes de l'ombre
moi qui viens d'un milieu quand même
relativement modeste et qui suis arrivé
à faire du cinéma je sais pas c'est bien
ou pas mais j'y suis arrivé je trouvais
intéressant de témoigner de ça je les ai
trouvés très intéressé très intéressant
aussi
ce qui est magique comme quand on fait
du cinéma d'ailleurs c'est une rencontre
avec les gens là ces ne rencontrer que
les plus jeunes c'était super de
d'abord à titre personnel c'était super
pour moi d'être au milieu des jeunes de
leur fraîcheur leur spontanéité
qu'est ce qu'un territoire la notion
varie selon la personne l'association
versa l'image a posé la question à ses
adhérents les réponses s'expose jusqu'au
31 mai au domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles les images sont signés
patrick jacques de dixmude territoire
portion identifiés et appropriée de la
surface de la terre de cette définition
cyclo pedic l'association versa image en
tire une exposition à chacun avaient
quartier libre pour exposer sa vision du
territoire donc parfois c'est un
territoire plus tôt descriptif
parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué on a
aussi une des visions c'est la notion de
tribus à la de la population d'un espace
qui délimite un territoire
on a aussi des territoires au niveau de
la photo animalière 150 photographies
entraîne le spectateur dans un voyage
sans fin résultat d'une réflexion
initiée depuis le mois de septembre
grand ou petit format couleur ou noir et
blanc dix neuf photographes se sont
prêtés au jeu et partagent leur vision
je fais beaucoup de photos animalières
en fait j'ai fait un focus sur les
libellules parce que ce sont des
insectes qui m'a qui me passionne il y
en a beaucoup qui ont disparu si on
enlève les mares si on enlève tout ça
disparaissent et donc la notion de
territoire pour moi est importante par
rapport à elle je suis parti du principe
que finalement faire une photographie
s'est posé un cadre s'est posée donc des
limites dans un espace et que ses
limites des limites justement un
territoire le territoire photographique
dans lequel on va y projeter un certain
nombre de choses dans lequel on va
interpréter un certain nombre de choses
c'est un territoire propre en france à
l'étranger sur la terre ou dans les airs
les photographes vous font découvrir des
trésors cachés de territoire plus d'une
dizaine d'artistes et un seul but vous
faire rire l'association tous pour
réussir lens ce samedi son premier
festival du rire et en plateau avec nous
deux de ses représentants que celle où
raoult chargé de relations entre autres
et chabot dos le président de
l'association
alors pourquoi déjà vous avez le lancer
ce festival d'où vous vient l'idée parce
que j'ai longtemps ce festival parce que
la ville de trappes en a ils sont dans
un état d'urgence on a besoin de se
retrouver et partager un peu des bons
moments comme comme on va faire ce
samedi 21 avril un plateau de plein
d'humoristes des hypnotiseurs et
d'autres encore d'autres nouveaux
talents de la ville pour c'est un grand
rendez vous qui va permettre d'échanger
beaucoup de choses le rire c'est
fédérateur ça permet à tout le monde on
aime bien rire et c'est pour ça on a
réfléchi pourquoi pas faire un truc mon
ristic invité des comédiens verts et qui
viennent un petit peu de partout et et
se régaler ce genre d'accord alors c'est
la première édition je le disais tout à
l'heure et dizaine d'artistes a répondu
présent des jeunes pousses et certains
qui qui monte
voilà bah ya déjà des humoristes qui
sont confirmés qui est un
qui sont actuellement qui ont déjà des
spectacles en cours tout ça est aussi
pro permetter aux nouveaux talents dans
la comédie de trappe comme ça ça va leur
permettre de ce projet sur mersen de
faire la première scène et d'échanger un
petit peu ce qu'ils ont à dire et nous
faire rire quoi ce qu'on a envie de rire
ces artistes que vous les ayez trouvé
par votre vos univers à tous les deux ou
ceux de l'association
il tombait milan parce qu'ils moitié
moins sûr a peur et il organise aussi
pas mal de choses avec mon association
et mon label est aussi un label de
production sur paris et puisqu'on
travaille un petit peu dans plusieurs
endroits et et tout donc par exemple le
dimanche dans une si c'est une grande
fille chasseurs paris de mes amis qui
s'appelle le wild rim de dimanche et il
organise deux autres comédies et c'est
comme ça que j'ai eu l'idée de défaire
ce festival pourquoi pas déplacé ses
humoristes là dans notre ville échanger
des bons moments tout ça comme ça ça va
éviter peut-être que les petits jeunes
s'affrontent quartier en quartier voilà
l'association 8c les moyens de réussir
tout à fait c'est aussi pour voir
permettre à ces jeunes de leur apporter
quelque chose au mieux de rester en bas
de l'ordre de leur quartier si notre
association peut les aider aussi bien
professionnellement que musicalement
puisque
parallèlement
j'ai aussi une association de musique mc
musique nous aidons dans la rédaction du
dossier de presse parce que bach pour
les présenter oui c'est piqué l'inde
aujourd'hui donc nous les aidons les
aidons aussi à trouver des scènes et
c'est pour ça que en lien avec l'artiste
chabot dont on s'est dit pourquoi pas ce
projet pourquoi pas leur donner une
chance et les faire découvrir aussi à
d'autres professionnels parce qu'on sait
que des fois même ne serait-ce que dans
des événements comme ça il ya aussi des
grands qui viennent voix qui viennent
jeter qui viennent chercher donc c'est
leur apporter quelque chose
et puis c'est un moment aussi pour les
parents de se retrouver avec leurs
enfants et ils ont roulé pendant les
goûts de chacun voilà
et puis oublier une journée les
problématiques et bien pas que le rire
et la chanson vous l'avez dit vous êtes
rappeur vous avez un hypnotiseur vous
avez ouvert à tous ceux qui voulaient
venir aussi j'imagine partager leur
passion très bien et votre association
c'est combien de personnes s'est depuis
combien de temps j'ai cru en 2009 sur
trappe
l'association est créée en 2009 ça fait
neuf ans que qu'elle existe et c'est ça
fait là un an et demi qu'on en sort
chercher nous mêmes on on voit
maintenant comment on peut développer
comme on peut travailler avec
l'association qu'est-ce qu'on peut
ramener ramener dans la ville de nouveau
pour que les petits les petits jeunes
soit on on essaie de les canaliser un
petit peu ce soit dans le sport dans
dans dans la musique la comédie tout ça
comme ça ça va les empêcher un petit peu
qu'ils qui s'affrontent ainsi qu'avec
les autres quartiers
ça c'est vraiment notre but c'est notre
vision omis de s'affronter pardon on est
en bas des sites et venez vous affronter
sur une scène c'est pas mal avec les
mots tout à fait c'est mieux que les
points voilà et puis notre association
aussi on va essayer de voir ce qu'on
peut faire aussi au niveau activité
pourquoi pas des sorties des activités
donc on a mis en place pour cette année
bien une petite adhésion donc qui va
être très sa manceaux n'ont cédé samedi
voir et puis la collecte c'est de ces
adhésions va nous permettre d'organiser
des projets pour les jeunes et pourquoi
pas au prochain coup de coeur parce que
c'est la promesse est premier mais ça
sera pas le dernier ça c'est sûr
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu en plateau alors le festival du
rire commence à 15h30 à la salle jean
baptiste clément de trappes ont par
manon à guyancourt où des élèves de
seconde du lycée de villeroy ont pu
tester leurs talents d'orateur ils ont
déclamé des poèmes écrits dans le cadre
d'un projet culturel et depuis le début
de l'année scolaire ils ont été épaulés
par un poète
aurélie rose
après plusieurs mois d'écriture et
d'entraînement ces élèves de seconde du
lycée de villa roi partage aujourd'hui
leur création dans le cadre du parcours
d'éducation artistique et culturelle un
projet qui a démarré en septembre
dernier
le but est de partager la poésie celle
qu'on lit celle qu'on apprend et celle
qu'on écrit soi même en étant dans les
traces des poètes qu'on étudie et en
suivant les traces d'un poète bien
vivant impôts est bien vivant qui se
nomme il gaudin les élèves ont pu le
rencontrer à plusieurs reprises lors
d'ateliers au début j'étais pas trop
chaud parce que c'est pas trop mon truc
les poètes où sa mère est comme c'était
yves godin après on a appris à le
connaître et tout et j'ai bien minime et
vous dit les aider à prendre confiance
en tout l'environnement qui était
guettée avec eux que ce soit l'espace
des gens qui nous a permis à chacun moi
y compris un de nous libérer de plein de
préjugés et donc d'avoir de l'à-propos
politique
une approche qui a conquis les jeunes
poètes yvon godin le personnage on a
bien aimé une amie tout à l'aise et j'ai
l'intention nous a plus aidé à être à
l'aise à comment rester nos prêts mais
il nous a beaucoup aidés sur l'écriture
aussi
moi ça m'a plu du coup j'ai pris mon
stylo ma plume et j'ai commencé à
rédiger
je pensais pas que moi je pouvais écrire
quelque chose pour moi c'était réservé
aux grands poètes la trentaine de poèmes
écrits par cette classe de seconde sera
prochainement éditée dans un recueil
intitulé les dormeurs du bal
un rendez vous à noter dans votre agenda
avant de nous quitter la ville de
versailles et le comité d'entente des
associations patriotiques d'anciens
combattants victimes de guerre et
militaires font appel à vos souvenirs
familiaux en novembre 2018 elle
proposera une exposition pour commémorer
évoqué la période et l'ambiance des
derniers mois de l'année 2018 dans la
cité royale
alors n'hésitez pas envoyez ce que vous
pouvez retrouver dans vos albums photos
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve maître du prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]